today's topic we've been away for a
little while and so i figured what
better way to come back
than to start off with um a video from a
channel that's really launched our
careers
jesus christ i knew i know what jubilee
so
they got a new video and apparently it's
worth watching so let's start let's do
it then
[Music]
oh man oh this haven't even started yet
i didn't even want to watch it
before we hate let's try
to appreciate what do you think
their goal is with this i want to go
into the
role let's go into the mind
of a jubilee producer right from the
people who brought you
derek i would view it more as
uh how we treat children that we love
we we control them but we control them
lovingly not as a slave
not as we're forcing them to do things
against their will right
from the people who brought you yeah
hey thank you how did you know
you didn't even plan that for the people
who brought you
that's not vegan what's your favorite
candy my favorite candy
most candies without gelatin in it
name one nerd sour sour patch kids okay
those aren't vegan
right for the people who brought you all
that okay what do you think
was their goal just create create
just create [ __ ] i don't think their
goal was anything it's just let's try to
flip something
let's try to do something really
interesting let's
try to let's try to let's try to let's
try to
let's try to let's
you know what it sounds like you're
saying you know what i'm you know what
you know what i look like right now
blind fury when he ripes woody wraps
you know what it sounds like though it
actually sounds like you're saying less
cheddar
it's time let's just shine
more cheese less chatter more gouda less
cheddar
well you know what leave a comment below
tell us do you guys think they had a
purpose
and it was what i described or do you
think it's just let's ch
[Music]
can we say like what we do we're like
whatever you are
so i'm a dancer i'm very physical i use
my body a lot i love bacon cakes i
always just like shove baked goods on my
friends
i teach acting to young kids i do mostly
musical theater oh my god because i'm a
weenie i know
you don't like musical dinner you met
theater students butterflies in the
skies
i can fly out twice as high take a look
read the book the reading rainbow
i can't go
anywhere yes i have
every time i meet someone they say i'm a
theater student i'm just like
just everything without them is just
extra it's just like it's just like
awkward you know i mean they're so busy
being other people they didn't know how
to be themselves
you know say that again again they're
not getting so busy
acting as other people they don't know
how to act and mistake i ain't mad at
that and i wish that every human
out there had the courage of their
convictions to walk through everyday
life
right and to be brave enough to be
themselves
calm down calm down
agitated upwards
one time i was on a date with the
theater girl we were making out
and then after we put like kind of
separated she went oh my god i like your
nose and i was like okay so
yeah your nose it's just so boop oh oh
and she went your nose is boopery
um but i'm single as all heck hey i
am a journalism major i'm also a student
i'm double majoring in psychology and
criminal justice
i'm also an actress i love to travel
i've been to india five times
okay so we have to do this should we
rank herself should we just like close
our eyes and like scoot to everything
we should be and yeah you know what i
mean just go for it on an individual
basis i think that's very smart
i feel like my personality is really
attractive my looks
i feel like i'm like okay like i don't
think anyone would look at me and be
like
oh i'm nervous how are we not going to
bump into each other did anyone take
this into consideration
sorry oh here we go everyone wants to be
humble i'm not that pretty you know
you're just a pretty oh my god
oh my god why did you oh my god why did
you oh my god
this whole little [ __ ] puffle yeah
this perfume where they go waffle
that's a good word right cluster [ __ ]
all my time off i've been opening up a
dictionary you know what i'm saying
all right oh nebulous
you think i'm out here playing i got
words gee
i guess i'll be one okay okay
cool beings i already love all right so
much dearly and i would date
all of you so does that make me a three
okay yeah i'll just stay here yeah
nobody really wanted to be lost and i
could kind of
feel that vibe so i was just like you
know it's fine
like nobody is a five really nobody in
your group
there's a lot of ugly people watching
this video like i'm not nick i'm a five
let's keep it above listen if you if you
think you're the five
we'll post a comment you know i mean
five uh let's stand up
and your and your picture better be your
picture yeah yeah yeah
i better not see no i don't want to see
no kakashi sensei
as your display picture okay i don't
want to see no sonic the hedgehogs
all right if you're five be a proud five
here's what i know
one four and five are going to be one
two and three i would probably think
they're gonna put
five and four at the top two she's gonna
be third and
black girl's gonna be fourth and then
big girl is gonna be fifth
that's what i let's see if i'm right
[Music]
she has a hole in this sock a big ass
hole in his socks
you know what i just understood what i
just understood why black porn star
with tim's on yeah you know
that's crazy do you want to start it off
geo over there and then
like just shift down i think michelle
was the most attractive
how she looked how she carried herself
and it just seems like someone that's
going to live an exciting life i guess
you could say or that you could have
like a deep conversation with
could you switch with her
i forget they can't even hear me
okay what would you switch i switched
her and her
you go over there all right thank you oh
those two okay all right
you over there
[Laughter]
personally for me she kind of looks like
kristen bell
and i i really like kristen bell so i
probably put her in
on the one or two position i think that
maria was the most attractive
for me it was just like her whole vibe
and like i liked how her hair was
just so so jorday
jorge you're gonna like maria right i
wonder why cabron
i'm just waiting for for for carlos
santana to come in with a tractor
[Music]
goes up she should be a four because
it's like meeting the middle i think
five and four switch the
we're gonna get ripped in u1 i don't
want to get the pointer here guys are
not afraid to be more blunt they were
straight up
hey you're attractive you're attractive
you're not but girls were like
i don't want to be rude you know we're
all beautiful in our own way
all right are we good we're good i'm
good we're walking in
yeah this is exactly what i expected was
gonna happen but it's also important to
know like
who's rating it is gonna change the
rating system definitely like if you had
five black dudes like they probably
would have rated that completely
differently yeah thick thick won't be
first
right they think it's gonna that's also
real so
you know and then jorge came on and he's
like um latina and you all went like
i went he went uh yeah exactly
that's o-r-a-l-e
yeah if i'm looking i'm like yo probably
pick the black girl first
i mean i want to be able to go to the
club make sure you can two step on me
yeah
the way the guys were ranking the girls
i actually think we were doing it mostly
by personality
you didn't even talk to the girl what
the [ __ ] are you talking about bro
holding the socks hole in the socks
there's a hole in whatever you said it's
a big hole in your thing
what the hell you talking about base of
personnel you didn't even talk to them
how could you base it on personality
they had hear muffs
were you talking about brother i was
super anxious about ranking them
my hands were getting all clammy i was
like really uncomfortable being the one
to be like putting them where i thought
well i was at five and now i'm here so
i'm like
thank you i don't know it's very
interesting i feel like
and you didn't she played that that that
last girlfriend
pretend she doesn't know she's yay yeah
we know those people
yeah i am a zero
stop lying i did think coming into this
like
cultural stereotypes would be a factor
them making me first kind of
shot that down i guess because i didn't
think they would choose like an asian
girl first
i think when i think of a male viewing
me as attractive or not versus a female
it's definitely different because in a
male setting if you're
judging me i knew that was going to
happen like i'm not stupid so like i'm
aware
of how others view me i was surprised at
them placing me at the bottom but at the
same time
i know out of a room of beautiful girls
that i was put in but from the jump
there was
there was no chance for me i was yeah
there was no chance there
me being the only black girl like i knew
that
i wouldn't really rank uh yeah
because american beauty standards versus
what people see people of color
it's different i like how the asian
girls like huh why y'all why y'all
trying to rub my shine i'm out here
defining oh
you mean beauty like wait a minute i got
ranked first
remember guys to be fair though in the
dating hierarchy
asian women do rank pretty high in terms
the guys that i interact with
they socialize more with black women and
they think more black women are
attractive
i think that the guys ranked the woman
from appearance more than personality
do you usually feel like you're the most
attractive person in the world
most of the time so there's a there's
the video how did you feel about like
the messaging and like
what did you think of purpose but there
was no message really
people view it's like things that we
already knew it's
we we people view people differently
women are gonna try
and the thing that women if you wouldn't
it would have been a different
experience if you wouldn't have the
girls talk to each other
just rate each other that's it
yeah it would have been a different
rating system because they
saw and they they started talking to
each other and have a feel for each
other
so right there and then it kind of
biases the whole thing you know i mean
here's something i also know like when
women are really beautiful they get a
lot of [ __ ]
for being very attractive and so a lot
of them try to compensate by like
putting themselves downs or not wanting
to do that so when you put them in a
situation where they're going to talk to
the people who they're engaging with and
have to judge themselves obviously
they're going to downplay themselves as
a means to be liked by other people it's
a very basic diplomatic skill that a lot
of people have so which makes sense
to me i think the the structure of the
experiment kind of was
counterproductive towards getting real
honest answers
um because you know if you come out
you're like i'm a 10.
even though you may be people will be
like you're a jackass because
we don't like people who admit their
strengths we want everyone to be super
humble or whatever
you know um and i think it's unhealthy
to be honest with you
what's unhealthy um downplaying yourself
for the purpose of garnering friends or
being liked by people not making you
feel like you're something that you
probably are yeah yeah like i understand
it's hard and i understand it's like
unfair that people judge you and be
softer looks and
uh is a reality but i don't think that
you should have to start downplaying
yourself as a means to
to be palatable to people and i know a
lot of attractive women who do that
and it's just like it's not necessary
but i get it
they've been going through the flat you
know what i mean yeah [ __ ] look at
the like girls
yo girls are vindictive man to each
other
it's it's a doggy dog world out there
for girls it's like whenever you have a
good looking one and you one that step
in the room all the other girls the way
they act the way
they talk to even men it's like yeah
yeah even man
but like it's it's it's it's a messed up
thing
when we have a good looking man we're
just like all right well all right but
we know how it is
we know what this about yeah all right
you tripping on them
but the way that the way women talk to
each other
and talk down at each other when there's
a good looking woman now
in the vicinity of of of of them talk
it's just different and it's
very rough i disagree because even for
men like even attractive dudes they'll
tell you like
unless attractive dudes will often times
be super insecure around them
not want to bring their girl around them
or think like oh the man so they don't
want to be around them that's a
different thing with
i'm not saying that they're not going to
be in there's not an insecurity or
something like that
something i'm saying yes of course
there's insecurity and guys are not
going to want to bring girls around them
or is it guys it's not even
attractiveness it's even
fame yeah you could be a butt ugly guy
and
i get that but the girls do
talk harsher than men we we
we're gonna the way men are gonna do
around good looking man is that we're
maybe not
gonna want to bring our girls around or
we're gonna like roll our eyes when
girls are gonna be talking about that
dude but we're gonna take the most of
the time we're gonna take the l
i disagree okay yeah from what i've seen
i've seen insecure dudes
flex around them they try to compensate
they try to do a whole bunch of stuff
and i'm saying that's not necessary i
understand that i've seen that too yeah
but i've seen you know there's money
or like fame like you said i see i see
what you're saying but i've seen much
more
like girls being
harsher whether it's in the club scene
or even in the work environment so i
mean we could we could agree to disagree
on that
but me working in clubs and stuff like
that when there's a good looking girl
around
hearing what the girls say and when
there's a good looking guy that has
cash often i don't say what you're
saying but i
often the guys sometimes either are
gonna are gonna
the guys are gonna be prone to be like
hey you know what i can't beat them
i'm gonna join them but the girls
they're like yeah no that this and that
um i actually thought this was a decent
jubilee video
um i think um the only got a
conversation going and i didn't cringe
throughout the whole process so
that's pretty cool um yeah tell us what
you guys think
why do you guys think people are so
uncomfortable with the ratings and
what are your thoughts throughout this
video you know more comments you leave
more discussions we can create
but uh we love seeing your your content
so yeah go check that out
also if you haven't subscribed already
please do so
i think like fifty percent of y'all who
watch this are not subscribed so hit
that button
we're gonna be uploading lots of videos
over in the coming months you know i
mean a lot of quality quant
so go watch that we also have a discord
which you can sign up to and have huge
discussions with their groups
and we got merch merch that's true check
the description below to see the link
but
you know i mean you want this hoodie the
hoodie is you want this hoodie the
hoodie's available
all right it says uh i love you in
spanish
there you go
[Music]
what you can't do